the jurogan experience that one i didn't
see coming those are those are way to
one side because what was supposed to
happen just run through here
well the thing is i one thing i did say
leading up to the fight like as they
were getting ready i said you have to
think
of all the times where someone's
underestimated someone you can never
underestimate an opponent you can't go
into a fight not nervous you can't go
into a fight completely sure that you're
gonna win when that other person is
hungry and scared because yeah weird
things happen when people underestimate
everything happened in fighting
everything [ __ ] that was nuts and that
what i saw as a fan from the outside the
first round the first cuff kick make her
fly yeah but
we know that part she's a strong she's
bigger
we all know that part yeah but then
everything comes in the other side if
you if juliana was mentally sad you know
prepare to die [ __ ] you i'm gonna take
this from you
the moment you take the first couple
punches and the ko guy don't stop you
yeah we said
through the years
every time conor couldn't stop somebody
what happened he go to stop sometimes by
the second fight with nate he he
survived and wound up beating him but he
didn't even though he didn't stop him
you don't but it don't happen all the
time but it's like it's it but he was
ready for that fight yeah but when when
you were like relying yourself like okay
i'm gonna stop you quick you're thinking
you're only gonna kill somebody good
luck with that well the thing that i was
watching in the first round when juliana
had the kimura and she was threatening
with the kimura at the end of the round
i was like ooh
like that looks serious
and she kept doing it she kept going to
it i'm like look as long as this fight
is on the ground in that kind of
situation giuliana is very dangerous and
if she can
tire amanda out if there's a way to do
it that's the way to do it
yeah i didn't saw that coming either
like i can lie until like yeah i knew
she would punch her in the face and make
her make her like slow down but when
this when they were exchanging punches
you can tell how much um
amanda was charging and when you charge
you get way more tired yeah she was
swinging for the fences like she was
like trying to take her out quick and
then when juliana was still there you
could tell like she was [ __ ] tired
yeah for for you to be a world champion
in two divisions and universally
recognized as the greatest woman fighter
of all time which is amanda is
it's unexcusable to be that tired in the
second round yeah unexcusable and just
standing in front of her just swinging
in front of her no movement side to side
standing right in front of her like
you're watching like a regional fight
but then you know how mental is the game
yeah you can have all the technique all
the power the moment you
doubt yourself and you take a step
backwards you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] that's why i take
i take more care
of what goes through my mind than how
much conditional training i can do yeah
because you can take
you can go way longer if your mind like
david goldman was talking about it in
those moments you're about to quick and
your mind is trapped in that thought
that i'm gonna quit
if you just tell yourself
i'm gonna go through hell i'm gonna [ __ ]
you up that thing is reversible yeah but
you have to want it you have to want it
that's why
chad also was saying something that i
don't agree with like he was basically
saying like i don't really think
um
that that
that was caused because uh juliana it
was more quitting one side but that
quitting was cause
for the dog in the other person too it
was caused by giuliani yeah
made her quit she didn't just quit on
her own you got to give julianna all the
credit a hundred percent when i heard
that this morning i was like wait a
minute you're not saying that i get it
she's the goat for one loss don't take
your title away right but that loss take
your title away for sure like the belt
you don't take the title of the goat for
all the achievements you have ko cyber
right all the people you beat you keep
that
but she make you quit you don't quit on
your own yeah she made her quit but the
way she quit was
crazy that joke no it wasn't uh choke
wasn't on it was on the chin right right
let's find the find the choke find the
uh the submission i'll tell you one
thing you don't need the you don't need
the hooks to
put somebody in conscious but you need
to get under the chin oh that thing was
that thing wasn't even there it was like
this right there was nothing yeah but
you know look
you can get that like that fulcrum choke
like what khabib did to conor
if you get the forearm on the back and
you crank the neck
but that requires a lot of strength yeah
that wasn't what was going on that was
an excuse no she was just like you know
what i want to live another day well she
was like she was exhausted i come back i
come back next time strong which
i think myself like this if you do that
once
you will do it again
well you know that is uh what juliana
said leading up to the fight juliana
said i'm going to bring her back to what
it was like when she was younger and she
would
about fights at the beginning yeah well
there was fights where she got exhausted
and she kind of like lost her way
and then she became the greatest of all
time and it's it's wild to see the
difference i think it's too close to the
pay-per-view time all the videos i'm
looking at are just pictures oh no find
it on my instagram
um i have the video on my instagram the
ufc lets me slide
yeah they let me uh you should i post
[ __ ] on the answer look it's the only
promotion it's only helping is yeah
wants to help the ufc more than i do you
can't control the video there you can't
control it i can only hit stop it oh
it's okay just show it to us just show
it to us yeah because that joke was like
it wasn't even cool so here it is this
is listen to the volume too because
we're going [ __ ] crazy me and dc were
going nuts i love it i was watching that
you guys were screaming
exactly what she said she was going to
do
that jab look at that jab in that right
hand
look at amanda look at that jam
yeah she don't have her feet on there oh
my goodness she's so tired her base is
gone
listen to that
john and the only professional when you
say that i was cranking up
big deep press for nunes
[Applause]
see now here it is her eyes are gone too
[Applause]
do you see some guys getting off some
deep chokes before yeah yeah yeah
because they have the fight on it yeah
she was like
i live another day yeah well i mean
dustin
i mean uh oliveira had to keep adjusting
on dustin before he finally got it that
was deep that was the moment he tapped
but might as well just guard us he went
behind the head you know he had the hand
behind the head and he got that ultimate
leverage too from that yeah that was
that that was charles oliveira is a bad
[ __ ] he is a bad [ __ ]
yeah the only thing that i was thinking
about it
without a
pulling the glove you wouldn't end on
top true that was so that was a cheap
move so it's like
remember when uh
when
chad mendes
was about to suplex alden the very first
fight and he grabbed the fence and he
got ko right after yeah that will change
a lot changes everything because the
grapple was full on deep
and may that make him roll to end on his
back and that round he took a lot of
damage yep yeah so it's like
if that would be a adjustment hey stop
right stop one stand up